we're literally um redefining everything
we do uh as a staff as a group
so
you know literally everything every
formation uh every route
every
run you know every route concept
how can we make this offense
which up until this point
has been good
we're trying to make it as
great as we can be
greg roman the new offensive coordinator
of the baltimore ravens talking about
the changes that will be made now that
lamar jackson is the clear-cut starting
quarterback
comments uh via podcast on the ravens
website so uh look you've got five guys
we were talking about this earlier five
guys who were drafted in round one last
year they've all passed the eyeball test
for now that doesn't mean they're all
destined to become pro bowlers that
doesn't mean they're all destined to win
super bowls i mean that's the thing is
these great young quarterbacks
proliferate through the nfl
you're still gonna have good teams and
bad teams you're gonna you could have 32
quarterbacks say these guys all look
great they can get it done they can do
everything they're still going to be
people losing these games and you're
going to have guys who end up being
quarterbacks of losing teams so as we
move forward with the five guys who were
taking in round one last year what can
we expect and i want to start with lamar
jackson he was the last guy taking in
round one the ravens were thrilled to
get him i the big concern there is can
he develop as a passer will he develop
as a passer and will he become anything
close to the weapon that he was at
louisville we were talking about this
yesterday he was actually better the
year after he won the heisman just the
rest of his team wasn't good enough to
put him in that upper echelon of heisman
consideration but this guy was special
at the college level how much of that is
going to translate and how much of it
will apply
when look you have an advantage it's
almost like when when bill belichick
first started running the 3-4
re-embraced i remember the 3-4 was in
vogue in the 70s and belichick kind of
brought it back in a big way 15-20 years
ago
it uh
it confounds quarterbacks aren't used to
seeing it peyton manning used to have a
hell of a time at the 3-4
the more you see it the easier it gets
so this ravens run based offense with
lamar jackson at quarterback it's so
different than what you usually see it's
hard to deal with but the more you see
it
the easier it's going to get and look at
what the chargers did they played the
ravens in late december
play him again
in january in the wild card round and
the chargers went into baltimore and
handled the lamar jackson offense so you
know he's going to need some weapons he
needs something in the running game i
saw somebody suggest maybe mark ingram
will sign with the baltimore ravens heck
maybe le'veon bell could end up with the
baltimore ravens by the time it's all
said and done but uh you need to give
him some weapons in the passing game and
you need to hope that that number one he
can develop as a passer number two he
can stay healthy that's my primary
concern for lamar jackson because if
you're going to run the ball that much i
don't care who you are if you are going
to be taking hits if you're going to be
running well you got to avoid taking
hits you got to take hits in a smart way
when you do take them that's the one
thing about russell wilson he
instinctively knows how to position his
body so he doesn't get blown up when he
gets hit and lamar jackson's gonna do a
need to avoid those big hits so he can
play as long as he can and also i think
the ravens are going to seriously
consider having rg3 around as the backup
that you know if you're going to have a
run-based offense with a quarterback who
is mobile then you have a backup who who
is essentially that same guy and not a
guy who's a traditional pocket passer
all right baker mayfield in cleveland
this one fascinates me stats because
freddie kitchens did a great job as
offensive coordinator now he's not the
offensive coordinator he's the head
coach so how much of that's going to
translate how much of that's going to
carry over
and and how much can baker mayfield take
a leap in year two we all expect it to
happen i mean we went from having kind
of no expectations and this is a
curiosity and let's see what baker
mayfield does to saying oh wow this
guy's great how's he going to respond
after an offseason of being the oh man
this guy's great young quarterback who's
going to be and think about this when
that schedule comes out
tony grossi was on earlier this week
talking about it prime time games prime
time games is baker mayfield going to be
able to get it done in prime time stats
or is it going to be another kirk
cousins sorry that's mean what do you
think is more important baker getting a
full off season with freddy kitchens or
a full offseason away from hugh jackson
and todd haley
well look look i i think to the extent
that this is working with freddie
kitchens and wasn't working with the
dysfunction that was there previously
and hugh didn't really believe in baker
mayfield wanted to have tyrod taylor as
the starting quarterback all year long
tyrod taylor another one who's going to
be available at a lot less than 25
million a year for a team that otherwise
could be considering nick falls should
have mentioned him last segment but uh
regardless mayfield now clearly the guy
and kitchens and company in position to
spend that full off-season program
training camp preseason getting baker
mayfield ready we've made that point
before with other quarterbacks but a guy
who gets thrust into it three games into
the season and wasn't the starter
every step of the way
now he gets a chance to be the starter
every step of the way there's a good
chance he'll be even better sam darnold
in new york i think he's going to be
what what we saw at the end
of the uh regular season last year when
he developed into
a much better quarterback than he was
early on i think adam gase is going to
get more out of him and there's a lot of
speculation that maybe le'veon bell
maybe antonio brown maybe there's going
to be some weapons there that will help
sam darnold improve and
i think that that makes for a
potentially interesting situation in an
afc east where
somebody eventually is going to step up
and challenge the patriots it has to
happen at some point they can't have a
hammerlock on the division for the next
hundred years josh allen's also in that
division as the buffalo bills
quarterback and i thought he was
surprisingly good the thing that shocked
me about him his willingness to put his
head down and run the football now he
got banged up in the pocket not while
running but he he's a dual threat and
he's got that rocket arm and i think the
bills uh were were better than expected
last year
because they kind of you know it felt
like they were moving in the right
direction but then they tore it all down
and now they're building it back up and
i think josh allen could be good and the
last one josh rosen he's the one who
knows with josh rosen right um they're
trying to circle the wagons in arizona
they're trying to make it look like
they're not interested in in kyler
murray they have to say that even if
they are interested in kyler murray but
rosen is the guy who i think has the
least around him
and is going to make it the hardest for
him in that division with the seahawks
with the rams with the 49ers if they can
keep their key players healthy rosen may
be a guy who could be a very good
quarterback but it may just not be in
the cards for him to to get i didn't
mean that in the cards
i did not i did not mean that i believe
me i didn't mean it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports